un jour il y a 15 ans tout a changé
[Musique]
vous étiez recouvert de ce fluide que
quelqu'un avait jeté dans les égouts je
ne sais pas ce que c'était mais ça nous
a transformé
étrangement nous sommes devenus une
famille
[Musique]
je suis le meilleur
les garçons
vous allez faire quelques courses c'est
tout
ça j'ai essayé de les raisonner on est
fait comme des rats
rejeté par la société et qu'on pouvait
faire tout ce qu'on veut vous feriez
quoi allez au lycée ou sortir avec une
fille vous imaginez le truc dans tes
rêves
de karaté je veux absolument tout savoir
sur vous et ben notre père est pas du
tout enragé tu viens de me convaincre
que c'en est un peu par la récente série
de crime perpétrée par Superfly personne
n'a jamais vu son visage pourquoi parce
qu'il liquide tous ceux qui croient son
regard
on a qu'à arrêter Superfly après tout le
monde nous trouvera sa femme il nous
acceptera
il va faire sans dire cette fois sous le
pont de Brooklyn
re vous êtes des petites tortues c'est
ça j'y crois pas il y a d'autres Mythos
bon alors vous roulez avec nous
des humains ne nous aimeront jamais
donc on va s'arranger pour que les
mutants dominent la terre
les humains ça dégage ah ouais le
scénario qui tue
on pourra pas l'arrêter mais on doit
essayer
[Musique]
mes fils michelangelis
Raphaël le courage et toi Léonardo le
sens de l'honneur
un souci avec la violence faut que tu
consultes